a radical shift in policy is how many
people are viewing this after 82
migrants were allowed to disembark in
Italy onto the island of lamb producer
were the country's new Foreign Minister
Louise DeMaio has justified this by
saying it's not to return to open ports
your career there's a big
misunderstanding about the safe port
given to ocean Viking it was assigned a
port because the EU adhere to our
request to take the major share of the
migrants it must be made clear that just
like with the previous government our
aim is to ensure that those who arrived
in Italy are redistributed to other
European countries well that's perhaps
understandable given that the
anti-migrant policies and the closure of
Italy's ports to charity rescue vessels
and to migrants was one of the most
popular policies instigated by the
country's former interior minister
Matteo salvini who saw his popularity
and the popularity of his party surge in
the time that he was in government now
he's been critical of this recent
development and he says it comes as a
result of pressure from other EU leaders
the Italian population is not a slave of
anybody we leave the whispers with Marco
and macron to the traitors of the
Italian people they have the right to
move and it's right to be tolerant it's
only fair to rescue these migrants but
decisions must be made because we can't
accept everyone they have faith in the
new government and I hope they will do
things differently I hope that with some
sense they will be able to govern
together for the good of Italy I was
once attacked by a Moroccan he looked at
me three or four times saw that I was
old and I had a gold chain he came
closer and just took it he might become
racist when these things happen to you
but we're not well any leaders are yet
to agree on a concrete policy with how
they will deal with the continued
migrant crisis a thorny issue that will
once again be raised when they meet
later this month in Malta and then again
as an EU summit next month in Luxembourg
but the reality is while the new Italian
governments say this isn't a return to
open ports many charity rescue ships
will now be seeing what's happened over
the weekend as the green light that
Italy's ports are again once open
you